what is shaking dude
hey ranch how you doing can you hear me
all right yeah you're coming in loud and
clear what can i do for you tonight
awesome so i'll be real quick with you
on the question so i do door-to-door
sales
in california and i was just recently
recruited to sell with this
team in columbus ohio so it's a bunch of
imagine almost like a fraternity house
of guys who are really really good at
selling door-to-door quick on their feet
very good at answering
questions um they study a lot
about sales and stuff and the thing is
when i saw their training
i realized this is where i need to be
because their training is phenomenal
their companies invested a lot of money
so i ended up
joining we're going to spend three
months in columbus ohio
selling and in a way this this
is applicable to the topic today because
a lot of these guys very high
testosterone
and it's a big competition on who can
sell the most accounts some of these
guys
they're 21 they're pulling in six
figures in a matter of three to four
months
and that's that's real money so i'm 22.
and the first thing i noticed when i
came on board was it's a lot like
baseball i actually went to
i played baseball in nevada university
of nevada reno which is i think rollo
zone arena
and i immediately started noticing these
guys
they'll get under your skin they like to
find weaknesses they'll be very nice up
front they'll be very friendly
and then we're all going to do a great
job this summer but i recently
took my i have an ltr i told her we have
to end things because i just don't want
to go through
the long distance for three or four
months while i'm selling
10 hours a day six days a week but i
took her to a
kind of a get-together and one of their
guys he
locked my girl in the room and this guy
was trying to be
my friend for the longest time i never
knew really knew why
he locked her in the room and he came
downstairs i ended up
having to kick his ass thankfully i take
muay thai
um and i haven't looked into krav maga
but i do
muay thai and kickboxing at the local
gym and
that happened so i already had kind of
an authority
but i can already tell there's little
snakes little guys who are starting to
whisper and i feel like
these guys are going to try to find a
way to get under my skin
because how long have you been doing
this door-to-door sales stuff
so i when i was playing baseball i was
on a pretty good scholarship drop
excuse me i dropped out of college
picked up the first shop i could find
thankfully it was sales sales found me
because i'm very good at what i do i did
dusk sales then i sold at a high end gym
for the equinox then i got my real
estate license and needed quick cash
so i started doing door to door and i
realized you can make six figures
how long how long have you been doing it
total of
door-to-door about nine months in
door-to-door specifically
okay and what do you want to be when you
grow up like you know once you've
gotten there my goal is to teach sales
and after this summer i'm going to go
and work for a very very high-end
real estate group here in san diego um i
don't knock ours for the rest of my life
but it's a good way to learn very
quickly
with the time frame you have on
someone's doorstep
so what's the time frame that you're
gonna give to door-to-door sales like
when are you gonna stop it
the goal would be no more than two
summers because like i said these guys
are making six figures and then they
take off the rest of the year traveling
and partying
my goal is to come back and work for
this real estate tycoon
learn the business and then go real
estate full time so i would like to sell
no more than two summers
um in in terms of sales before i go full
time into real estate
okay so um i'm assuming like you're
ambitious and you want to make some
serious bank
and there's probably less than five five
ways where you can make serious money in
your life and one of the ways is high
ticket
sales right and high ticket sales does
not involve door-to-door sales
um if you're in real estate it's high
price point real estate
like you know multi-million dollar
properties ideally like five million
dollars plus
plus so if you're in california in a
high-end real estate market
you can find that there um you know you
can move to luxury vehicles you can move
to yachts you can move to planes like
all of these things do really well the
funny thing you know that starts to
happen once you start moving into these
luxury sales items is you start to see
more and more hot women in that space
than men
because the guys because the people with
the money buying the [ __ ]
are usually older guys and boobs and
butt
with a check is gonna sell better than
you know sausages right so right
um just understand that sales is really
important and i think it's a good
skill to learn but i wouldn't spend two
two summers at this door-to-door stuff
you can probably learn everything that
you need to this summer and then
and then move on to some pastors that
are going to lead towards that level
that you're looking to get to
right i see what you're saying elliot
says
join the jehovah's witnesses for
apprenticeship
you know what's funny is a lot of the
guys who i work with they started
selling
christianity and now they do
door-to-door but like i said these guys
they're making a lot of money and i'm
just trying to find
how do i separate from the pack and i'll
let these guys drag me down
because i spent my entire life playing
baseball trying to make the major
leagues and in that frame
i learned so much about who to stay away
from i feel like i pretty good intuition
so i'm trying to figure out so again the
the
five types of enviers and there's a cast
that i did about a month ago
on before the train records i think it's
two before the title is envy
yeah the leveler and they tear down
anyone that's achieved something great
they try to bring them down to the
mediocre level
number two is the self-entitled slacker
they feel like the world owes them
attention praise even though they lack
the discipline to do the work
number three is a status friend they
always measure people via social status
they envy those of higher status and
envy those who enjoy certain privileges
number four is the attacher they don't
have a calling in life so they attach
themselves to people and brands
and uh you know others that have a sense
of purpose they envy and ultimately
attack the person
they've attached to that's what you see
a lot in the manual swap you see a lot
of these attachers that
try to like leach on to your good name
and brand and drag you down to the [ __ ]
with them
and the fifth one is the insecure master
uh they are an insecure person who holds
high positions in society
secretly doubts are worth and therefore
they envy more talented
subordinates you're gonna get that from
your boss you know if anybody
um so it's really the other four that
you got to look out for but
yeah check out that cast there's a lot
of good information in that you know
when it comes to that but
i like what you do man you know it's
good questions uh sorry to hear about
the
sports career but um yeah
plan b plan c whatever man you just have
to pivot like you know you eat sulk
like a embarrassing [ __ ] or you get
down to work and you double down and you
make it happen just find something else
that works for you if you're good at
sales
master that skill it's useful it comes
in a hand it comes in handy in a lot of
areas in life
yeah definitely i really appreciate the
book uh phenomenal reads all i'll keep
in contact i'm looking forward to
joining the men's community and um
yeah i'll uh i'll keep in contact
you got it man seattle thanks
you